elon musk got pissed off this week
elon musk is angry about a new bill that
includes a 4 500 tax incentive for
electric vehicles built by companies
with unions it's an insider story
democrats have proposed a bill with a
4500 tax incentive for electric vehicles
built by unionized
companies unionized companies musk
tweeted that the bill has been
engineered by lobbyists for ford and the
united auto workers union the bill also
grants a 7 500 base consumer incentive
for new ev sold in the us and it would
allow foreign made cars to claim that
incentives for five years this provision
would apply to four cars assembled in
mexico in a follow-up tweet replying to
a twitter user who said president joe
biden
would be making america's made cars a
priority musk said
uh wouldn't musk say
it doesn't have it here so musk said
something though yeah
and tagged the president's official
account anyways he took a shot at him
uh david if you can pull up uh the tweet
so we can see something like
how is this going to help americans yeah
and also yeah don't forget earlier this
year the dsa tried to put a plant in one
of uh the democratic socialists of
america tried to put a plant in one of
musk's texas um
operating places where he went in there
and tried to convince everybody to
unionize and elon musk said he was like
unionized tomorrow and i will get rid of
everybody's stock incentives so
why i don't know why you guys would do
this we're making tons of money together
you know and also man look this is not
just electric cars by the way pat this
is
most of uh joe biden most of the quote
unquote human infrastructure investment
that's happening in this green new
recovery act that they're about to drop
on us it's it's all going to the unions
and it's all going to the union
specifically because what do those
unions do they kick back where to the
democratic powers this this re this re
human infrastructure
is a war chest for democrat politicians
he's still sleeping is what he said he's
still sleeping yeah sleeping he said
yeah
but by the way going back to it then
this validates why the richest man
doesn't have the power i disagree
completely so you're saying elon musk
has power no but but the richest see the
richest man has power but you're talking
about
maybe i misunderstood you're saying like
super second richest man so ford ford
has a ton of money whoever is running
ford has a ton of money as an individual
the richest billionaire in america the
president well maybe you're right but my
thing is this the president is all the
way at the bottom of the list and i
still believe that because without those
unions joe biden isn't doing anything
these these
people know this is bad for america and
they're doing it anyway because they're
bought and paid for by by these lobbies
they're bought and paid for yeah so the
politician is down on that list
my big thing is this and maybe you guys
can answer this because you guys have
better foresight all right
what is the end goal of all this what is
what is the
5 000 yard view
three four five years from now
there's there's not these aren't stupid
people that are doing these remarkably
stupid things what are they looking to
accomplish what is the end game here
i don't think anybody just really knows
nobody knows i mean i think that uh if
you're super left-leaning you're you're
hoping for some sort of
equality where everybody is the same but
that's not true because they want to be
running stuff right and we don't really
know who's really in charge i mean you
hear joe biden he's i'm instructed to
ask them the question so no we don't
know we don't really they're going to
get mad at me if i answer questions yeah
yeah or when they shut them off in the
middle or you know one of the things i
thought was very interesting is the
press's response to him turning around
and just walking away versus trump would
sit there and just get annihilated where
they're coming at him coming out and
kind of he'll literally just be like no
more questions walk away and they say
thank you that's like such a different
thing
what do you think what is the what is
the 10 000 foot view what is going on
worldwide you got two types of people
man those who are driven by uh
freedom and those who are driven by
control and force it's power versus
force you know there's two ways to get
it one is through choice one is through
force
uh those who are uh driven by leave me
alone let me go build my life and do
what i want to do and make my money
they typically piss off the people that
want to control because they don't give
them a time of day and the other person
eventually goes and finds a different
way to gain their power for example the
other day i'm on the phone with ford gt
asking them for the gt the new the gto
what do you call it uh the new ford yeah
the the whatever the gt is the the one
from the movie versus far it's like a
million auto car but i'm on the list buy
stock and ford got it check so i'm on
the phone with this guy and i'm talking
to the guy i'm like yeah so you know
i've been on this list year and a half
we're going back and forth i'm like
here's this guy steve all these guys
that have vouched for me and you know
galpin and he says yeah i can't help you
and one minute conversation two minute
conversation five minute conversation
ten minute conversation
and the guy's like i can't do nothing
for you i can't help you is there
anything else i can help you with he's
talking like this right you know you
know i get off the phone you know what i
said he said i said a 20
an hour person has more power than i do
yeah he has the power of no
folks who work at dmv
who freaking get off of their job is to
be able to tell you whatever the hell
they want to tell you because they don't
give a if you write a yelp review
for them you got freedom people you got
control people freedom people want to be
able to say i don't like this restaurant
i'm going to buy this place and run it
better you don't want to do this i'm
going to buy this and i think i'm going
to build it into a better home better
building everything to them is that
and then the other guys who are power
hungry who don't want to do the work of
a capitalist will look and say
you know what he's really pissing me off
he didn't respect me he didn't follow my
rule he didn't follow my guideline i'm
going to create new laws i'm going to go
and make his life a living hell not by
competing with you but through laws so
this is a very interesting game man do
you think it's like they want like a
global one-world government i think it's
control buddy i think it's a control
game i think the mission is to control
the people they hate the most which is
the
job creators it's the capitalists they
can't stand the job creators because
look
you know uh uh my story like why you
just heard his story here's a guy that's
tama cocaine heroin all this other stuff
right and now he's built a business
nearly half a billion dollar company
that we're talking about 250 employees
and has an incredible life it looks like
channing tatum sounds like charles brown
there you go could have been an actor
magic aaron magic area magic singer
that's what the nickname it's moving
forward you got to get him a shirt magic
singer man no magic karen i'm on it yeah
chief of staff
so you got guys are like look you know
i'm gonna go build my business so in
school how many kids were supposed to be
the guy
like how many kids who were like valid
they followed the rules so well and i'm
supposed to be
and the next thing you know this
freaking kid that's a d student c
student b students like and everybody in
school is talking about that guy and it
was supposed to be that guy you don't
think that guy deep down his side for 12
years he's the guy he just described all
of brooklyn but for four years this
guy's the guy so yeah then they're like
you know what the way i'm going to get
even by going and being a lawyer and
creating laws the way i'm going to get
even by being a politician it's a very
weird dare this plumber make more money
than me i have four degrees i have four
degrees how dare this trucker make a
quarter million dollars i have my phd
because in their mind they've been sold
that everything with success starts with
you having a degree yeah so that paper
is worth so much to them so to to be
able to save that they sacrifice for
eight years to follow the rules now you
mean to tell me those rules are a little
bit broken
i'm i cannot buy that i have to protect
my ego i'm going to go out dude that's
such a that is such a good point because
that's literally what they're doing with
the with the vax they're like well they
took it so they're allowed to they're
they follow the rules they can they can
go to the restaurant i mean you're
talking about trudeau literally just
said that the people that follow the
rules get to live life and the people
that don't they do not get to be in our
society and it's like whoa dude like who
are you to even remar you're the prime
minister how can you say something i go
back to your interview with uh
um
jordan peterson remember you asked him
about it and this was years ago before
which one which question oh but he
called him a weasel oh my god and this
was out before the world even knew who
they were
go to youtube type in uh type in uh
jordan peterson and justin trudeau and
he just he just won a uh very hotly
contested uh re-election type in jordan
and then put justin
just put yeah and then put justin there
you go that'll come up
uh how long it's like it's a short clip
i think move off of it to see how long
it is
move okay yeah this had to be three four
years ago man make it a little bit make
it bigger
can you press mute on that bro like it's
just
holy david
what though
maybe it's pissed off at somebody sorry
sorry i'm sorry mom but you're saying
you gotta go hey we gotta pay listen
can we get audio now or no you're not
gonna give it to us oh man who
capitalizes go back go back a little bit
name of his fault
go back a little so i asked him what he
thought i did keep going back keep going
back i asked him about
i'm giving speed round and i'm giving
names i said what are your thoughts
about justin trudeau this is his answer
click on it trudeau justin trudeau um
that i just shake my head at that okay
oh man who capitalized without virtue on
the name of his father
wow
yes wow is right he had an ounce of
character he would have never run
listen i'm not happy about him
he had no right well he had a right he's
a citizen he can run he didn't earn his
name
not impressed
why do you say that this specific
because
his father was very famous sure and so
that put trudeau at a tremendous
advantage with regards to
moving into a leadership position in
canada it's not excusable you should
move ahead on your own merits especially
if you're daring to do something like
run a country
it's like it's too you you have a moral
duty if you have the advantage of a
nation you have a moral duty to
supersede the accomplishments of the
person who bore that name and gave it
its weight before you dare capitalize on
it in the public sphere and there's
trudeau did none of that he can he knows
how to behave he knows how to act in
public he had the upbringing for it
other than that there's nothing there
not that i can see and if there was he
wouldn't have run the way he did
he's not not an impressive person in my
estimation
some strong opinions there's so many
ways there when he he appointed
50 of females to 50 of his cabinet
because it was what do you say it's well
because it's 2015 it's like no
quarter of your elected members of
parliament were female
if you would your job was to pick the
most qualified people period regardless
of their genitalia because they're
leading the country you pick the most
qualified people steady abdicated his
responsibility to make those difficult
decisions and then wallpapered it over
with a this casual virtue of well i'm
going to promote women it's like no
you're going to promote competent people
you weasel
no excuses composite right now i'm
trying to hold myself from laughing
looking at my face
yeah he is not a i think it's fair to
say he doesn't like uh justin trudeau oh
congrats prime minister on on your on
your narrow victory yeah yeah he really
doesn't like him no he really doesn't
like him you know
have you seen the story of how jordan
peterson became jordan peterson you mean
like going the quora question and all
that and
when he was in school and the trans uh
the debate took place and he came out
public about it next thing you know he
got tens of millions of views and then
they interviewed him and the rest is
history jordan peterson becomes jordan
peterson jordan peterson next thing you
know he's in dallas
next thing you know he's in doubt can we
also give a shout out to pat's hair so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]